Hello, welcome everyone. It is September
17th, 2025. We are in active inference
gueststream 120.1 with Emanuel Adfa
Olasupo who will be presenting
modeling thought in time, a physics of
temporal intelligence as the next
frontier of AI. There will be a
presentation followed by a discussion.
So if you're watching live, please write
any ideas or questions in the live chat
and thank you for joining Emanuel to you
for the presentation.
>> Thank you Daniel. I appreciate the um
the invitation. Um it's uh I'm
incredibly humbled by um you know the
opportunity to to give this talk. uh the
title actually is not model in time. uh
but this is the paper that I think uh
connected you and I uh and so I just
wanted to start the presentation by sort
of uh clarifying or motivating the talk
based upon this paper this preprint that
I had published um and just to give a
short summary of what the paper is about
um you know the argument is that the uh
current LLMs that um are being used
right now both in the industry and in
academia. They um have what we call a
temporal blindness problem which means
that they um do not represent time um in
the lived sense right as as humans do.
And so if the goal is to achieve
conscious AI or AI that mimics human
cognition um and humans ability to
manipulate thoughts and emotions then uh
this paper argues that time is um a
foundational uh fe feature or uh that
needs to be represented akin to how
humans um experience time in the sense
of thinking in time and so on. I'll get
back to this towards the latter part of
the presentation but I just wanted to
motivate
uh the the lecture uh based upon uh this
paper the the the actual title of the
talk is uh uh temporal intelligence and
the emerging properties of consciousness
um indeed you know I'm going to sort of
to break this talk into three components
the first is I'm going to
idea of course defined and process it,
right? And so this is a type of process
in that um one would argue supports
temporal cognition by structuring how
information is organized over time and
enabling the system to become more
predictive and generative and generate
expectations about the temporal sequence
of impendent inputs. Right? And so that
coarse course defined process and that's
the first part that I'll talk about and
I and I'll talk about the mathematics
that perhaps governs that process both
within biological systems but also
artificial systems.
The second part of of this of this talk
is going to be uh on this idea of
predictive remapping. Um and and this is
an example of what I would think of as
temporal cognition and action, right? Um
um this is informed by um this idea of
active sensing, right? Uh this idea that
um cognitive systems must move in order
to compute information in the world,
right? And so I will also uh speak a
little bit about this. Um and then the
third part is the more um um
speculative or perhaps more um has is it
has the potential to be more uh paradigm
shifted if um one or myself or groups or
others anyone can achieve this this idea
of uh the emergence of thought right so
so how does your thought emerge how do
they flow and synchronize with other
people's thoughts and Can we achieve a
mechanistic view of consciousness?
Right? Because that I think is key into
achieving AGI, right? Artificial general
intelligence. And so th those three will
be the so so this typeight structure
would be kind of how I um uh go about
giving this talk.
And so
you know I normally approach questions
with physics and mathematics. All right?
So I'm a theoretical physicist. My my my
case is theoretical physics. But you
know I I I normally use the two to try
to understand the phenomenons that I
study and I particularly look at complex
systems particularly biological systems
to explore that and so that is important
to sort of highlight my biases right we
all have biases in which we use to sort
of inform how we think about the world
right um
so this idea of course defined I've I'm
illustrated here in this figure right So
what you see here is at least hopefully
what you can appreciate here is that as
you move towards the right this scene
gets more fine right and this is the
general principle of course defined
processing
and so what I'm showing here is a
cartoon of neurons in the brain
um that turns out they compute each part
of this processing right and so you have
these these early cells this this where
I've represented here late cell
bifphasic and late and so it turns out
that in the in the in in the mice's
brain there are neurons that compute
each part of this kind of uh uh stage in
course define and you know you can sort
of see in this cartoon here or so in in
this in in this experiment with Parker
at all where you have the mouse moving
along this vert virtual world right and
its neural activity is being recorded
during that sort of task that is being
asked to perform
and you know the work this work here
that I'm presenting is done with
Christopher Neil at the University of
Oregon and he basically pioneered the
field of active vision and what's very
profound about this is that this is such
a break from how bi biologists and
neuroscientists do experiments because
now these animals aren't headfixed
right? But they're actually moving in
the world akin to how we as organisms
move into the world and collect
information. And so in this paper they
found this coar defined processing
phenomenon which I've illustrated again
here in cartoon right but I I want to
emphasize that coarse defined processing
is quite um ubiquitous and what that
actually means is that you can actually
um you know there are papers that have
published course defined processing in
other sensory modalities
herin smell taste touch and so let Allow
me to give you a simple example. You can
imagine you are in a group of crowd and
you meet your partner for example and
you you spot her at a distal location.
What you might first do is sort of hear
this sort of global and coarser voice of
everyone and then as she approaches you
closer you um kind of finetune the your
auditory uh uh system in a sense. your
brain will do that and then you start to
focus on a singular voice. And so that's
an example of this course defined
process and operating in the in the
auditory system, right? And so you can
find this process um across sensory
modalities and it's not just across
biological systems but it's also
artificial systems, right? And so the
lost paper that I cited here, you know,
they use coarse defined process and to
sort of optimize the graph or the grip
sorry of of robots. So you can imagine a
robot extends its arm, tries to reach
for something. It first needs to kind of
get an understanding of the general area
of the scene and then over time we'll
understand oh this is a cup so I have to
hold it in a particular way in order to
maintain the grip right and so course
define excuse me the point that I want
to make here is that it's a it's a
ubiquitous way by which biological
systems and artificial systems process
information right
and so what I am interested in
understanding is what are the
mathematics what are the computations
that these systems are performing in
order to achieve the output that I've
shown in this sort of nice illustration,
right? And so the first thing, you know,
um and so and so let me dive into that a
little bit. So and and and again I I I
am aware that perhaps people that are
watching have different um um come from
different fields. So, I do apologize if
if it's a little bit too complicated or
or um I haven't explained it um as as as
as as well as I would have liked, but
let me take a stab at this. So, what you
see here is we're going to we're going
to try to understand this phenomenon
using what we call a recurrent
artificial recurrent neural network,
right? And so the hallmark of these
networks is one they are connected right
to each other. So let's just say for
example you see E and I there's a line
that connects E and to I and I to E.
They also have self connections, right?
So you see that E is connected to
itself. I is connected to itself and
they also have the ability to to to to
to get input, right? External input. And
so these features or or or these
components make up a recurrent neural
network.
And they also go in multiple directions,
right? So it's not one way, right? like
a feed forward direction but also
feedback and so on and so on. And so
people in the past have have used these
networks to try to understand
phenomenons in the brain for example.
And one of those is Murphy Murphy Miller
uh 2009 where they published this paper
called balance amplification.
And so allow me to try to explain a
little bit of what this means. What does
it actually say? Right. So here is so
we're going to be working with ENI
networks right and these are excitatory
and inhibitory networks in the brain in
the in the biological system and so here
shows the equation we call this a rate
model equation first differential
equations where you have E here which
represents the excitatory parts of that
network right and then you have the
inhibitory parts of that network so we
have R which represent the rate right of
the network we have W represent the
weight matrix
And then you have I which represents the
um internal or external input that the
system will get. And so you have this
first order differential equation that
basically will tell us we we think of
this as the governing equation. It will
tell us how the network behaves over
time.
And so
this is the tradition that I I I was
working from when I wanted to understand
the mathematics governing uh course
define. And so what I have done is
basically I took the same governing
equations right. So E here just
represents I the same way. So this
represents just the external input and I
have solved this equation in a
fundamentally different way. And so that
equation and the solution for that
equation is what we call what we think
of as uh the course defined solution.
And so this solution here, what is
unique about it is that instead of each
unit in the network having a single time
by which it it's perturbed or
responsive, it actually has a
heterogeneous
uh uh um it has the ability to have each
neuron has the ability to be to have its
own temporal dynamics.
And you can imagine if you want to
understand something like coarse define,
you need a temporal handle in order to
kind of play with and parameize in order
to try to simulate whether or not the
model can achieve the particular output.
And so that is the the the the novelty
of solving this particular equation in
the way that I've solved it. And this is
kind of like the first type of this is
the this is the first time that such a
equation has been solved in this manner.
And I think of this as a general form of
this uh solution because it can be
generalized to a lot of other things,
right? So you can imagine it could be
generalized to
um you know um uh not just vision but
you know different sensory organisms uh
sorry different sensory modalities like
audition and so on. as so long as it has
this handle of time and something that
is trying to um uh uh um some a
preferential uh object in this case
let's say vision right and so
um
this um cartoon if you may right this is
the case when if you were to draw a
diagram of the neuron um two neurons for
example right so E and I but this
diagram is basically showing more of a
population representation of the network
and we're going to think of the network
as not just E and I but we're going to
think of them as having two different
modes. So you can imagine the network
interacts with each other and E subtract
and you have what we call the difference
mode. So you have E and I whereby
they're kind of competing with each
other, right? And you have another mode
where you have E plus I and the sum and
and they're summoned together in a
sense, right? to produce some type of
effect. I know that's a mouthful that's
a little bit hard to process, right? But
I just what I want you to take away from
it is that when we look at these
networks, we're going to look at the
modes by which these networks operate
within. So we have the sum mode and we
have the difference mode. And it turns
out that the difference mode, right, is
what actually creates the initial
amplification in the system. So let's
say for example, when E and I are
imbalanced, you have this initial
amplification. That's where you can
that's how you can maybe understand the
initial parts of this of this time
series. So in this case here E and I
they're imbalanced the network amplifies
right based upon its feed forward
connection to E plus I and then as this
minus W plus uh gets stronger you get an
inhibition and then the network goes
down.
And so this is the type of network that
and so this is the type of behavior that
we would expect.
And so remember the goal here is to
simulate um coarse define processing
right and so on the on B here is the
experimental results all right that that
I've shown um earlier in in in the
cartoon right and then here is the the
the the response of the network that I
just showed you when we don't solve the
equation the way that we uh the way that
I've solved it uh with the course
defined solution and you know you don't
have to be genius to realize and see
that you know these two are not the
same. Right? And so what this is saying
is that the way the the the way by which
these governing the Murphy Miller solved
this equation cannot produce coarse
define.
But what if we used the coarse defined
solution the one that I noted earlier?
What you start to see is something a
little bit it starts to resemble B,
right? But here's the catch.
This is this simulation here is the case
where there is no input into the
network. So this is actually imagine you
have a netbook or you have a system
imagine I took a ball and I put it on
top of a hill right because of the and
and I didn't touch the ball at all
because of the uh the structure or the
architecture of of the hill the ball
will just roll down right so you can
think of that as the internal dynamics
of the system where there is no no one
pushed the ball there it's just
basically the system that you're trying
to understand and how it behaves and So,
but at the same time, you see that it
doesn't quite mimic B. Now, if I create
an input into E and I,
you can see that D rep D and B looks
very similar. So, what does it actually
mean? What does this actually mean? What
this means is that when you think about
course define, when you think about
systems in general, it seems that
systems have this internal structure
that is almost tuned or prepared to
behave or be amplified in a way that
represents the way in which the inputs
um kind of favor if you may, right? And
so basically what this is saying is that
you know in short
um you can understand course defined
using these governing uh this solution
that I that I have um that I have um um
um sort of put forth
e just to not complicate things any
further
this or this is my I can't get feedback
from anyone but Danny can you see my
screen can you see my m Perfect. So here
you see that E so so so on the Y ais
here is the kind of distribution of how
I set the time constants of each neuron
because if you remember in in my
governing equation each neuron can have
a different time constant right and so
this here shows that for this kind of
like let's take for example this trace
here that represents a certain class of
neurons neurons, the early neurons. I
set the excitatory neurons to be slower
than the inhibitory neurons, right?
Because you know the higher the value,
the slower, the lower the value, the
faster,
right? And then you can see that for
this set of neurons, I set it to be the
same thing, right? Excitatory neurons
are faster than the inhibitory neurons,
but you can see that the net average of
it is slower. So you see this difference
between excitatory and inhibitory. You
see the peaks different.
But you can see for example the
bifphasic it's almost a flip where the
excitatory neurons are slower or faster
than the inhibitory neurons. And so this
is something that now the
experimentalist can go and say okay
let's measure specifically the
inhibitory neurons and see whether or
not they actually represent or
recapitulate the model's predictions.
Right? And this is kind of the point of
like why you know some you know for
those that are not necessarily
uh interested in modeling and
mathematics you might wonder like so why
why model these things right it's
because these models will generate
hypotheses and intuitions that
experimentalists can now go and test and
say ah okay you know uh maybe in the
bifphasic neurons right in the bifphasic
group the one that looks like an S right
based upon Emanuel's uh uh uh uh uh
predictions
We expect the when we measure the time
of the inhibitory neurons, we expect
them to be slower than the excitatory
neurons, right? And so this is kind of
um you know what you know we did when we
tried to understand uh whether or not
these equations actually recapitulate
the biology.
So you know so that's the first part of
what I want to talk about this idea of
course define and how it kind of it kind
of gives you a hint as to how systems
kind of are how how the functional
architecture or the or the structure the
internal dynamics of the system is
almost prepared to process information
in a way that makes sense right in a way
by which is economically efficient or
energetically efficient
right and so the second part I'm going
to talk about this idea of what I call
retinal topic mechanics.
This is a little bit more um of the
physics uh side of me informing
um um some of these uh questions that
people have been trying to solve for for
many years. So
um should I wait for questions or should
I continue to go Daniel because it's
it's a bit of a first part. Let's
continue.
Excellent. Okay. So the the second part
here I'm going to talk about this idea
of predictive remapping. And so retinal
topics is remapping is basic retinal
topic mechanics is basically a field
that I have put forth right a hybrid of
physics and neuroscience.
And you know the the the the the the
framework came about based upon this
notion of or this idea of um uh uh um um
uh um um motion blur that happens when
you make eye movements. So here I'm
showing a human eye. Here I'm showing
the mouse uh the the the eye of a rodent
making eye movements. And then here I'm
showing the eye of a m of a mount um
sorry a drosophila which is like a a fly
in a sense right and you can see that
all of these systems across scale they
they make eye movements right they they
actively make eye movements around the
world to try to collect information
right
and one of the things that that happens
is that whenever you make an eye
movement
you experience this kind of motion blur
right like but sorry you don't
experience it but That's actually what
happens. And so your brain needs to find
a way to kind of eliminate and cancel
this motion blur so you can see and
experience the world in a very
continuous and fluid manner. And so one
of the questions that neuroscience and
physicists and mathematicians have been
trying to answer for many years is how
does this happen? Why is it that you
know you don't experience what we you
would experience if you were like taking
a picture with a camera for example.
Imagine if the train paused you and you
try to take the picture right of this
fast train with the camera. You would
experience the blurriness of that train.
But you and I make these eye movements
all the time. If you think of the eye as
a camera, but we don't experience this
motion blur. How does the brain achieve
that? Right? That's really the question
that informed this uh this this
computational framework that I
introduced.
And so many people think of neurons as
perceptrons, right? or like a ther
thermometer, right? Where you know,
imagine you had a thermometer, right? It
would give you the measurement and it
would go back down, right? Or perceptron
where it's a linear weighted sum of the
inputs that you put into the network.
And that's basically the foundation of,
you know, AGIS, right? Where you have
these perceptrons and and they're
performing these operations.
And so with this, you know, I radically
turn things on its head and I think of
these I think of neurons as
spring-loaded senses, especially because
I'm interested in this idea of movement
and active sensing. So it's not that the
neurons themselves are moving, but
they're they're they're they're getting
information from different parts of the
brain that is almost um tethered to
where in space they need to acquire
information. Right? So you can imagine
if I wanted to look here, right? Because
I have these two monitors, so it looks
like I'm looking away. But imagine if I
if I wanted to look here, right? Right.
I would have to sort of allocate some
resource towards this part of the visual
scene, right? In order to achieve some
level of uh perception, right, or some
desirable outcome. And so what you see
here is not the neurons themselves
moving but how the brain or how these
neurons are operating like springs in
order to allocate different uh neural uh
resources in different parts of of space
in this case uh visual space. So A here
is sort of um you know uh this spring
sort of being attracted to this moss
right um b here is a case where it's
unresponsive. So you can imagine a
maladaptive case where you know you
don't want to pay attention to something
and so you you self-inhibit right or
maybe a disease model where you can't
pay attention ADHD you can imagine hair
C being a case where you hallucinate
right so instead of you responding to N
you start responding to something else
right um and this larger uh uh uh field
that you see is what I refer to as
elastic fields these things have no uh
empirical support yet, but there is
something that I think is foundational
in understanding active sensing and and
active vision, right?
And so I'm not going to go too much into
details of this model. There's a paper
that you can read uh read where I
published in physics review where I
outline comprehensively this these
equations and and how the prediction
goes. But in short, I bring together a
range of papers that show that hey, like
maybe what the brain is doing it's it's
it's it's undergoing these predictive
shifts prior to an eye movement. And
these predictive shifts are what kind of
blunts
uh this motion blur that that would
normally occur. Um but what I found in
this paper just to just to conclude is
that these uh these uh these uh these
processes right these predictive
processes they're all happening but
they're happening at distinct windows in
time. So for example you can imagine if
I wanted to look at an object that is
here
the peripheral moss would be the thing
that is actually pulling the system
prior to me making the eye movement. And
so that predictive remapping of the
neurons right of the springs that would
go prior to me making an eye movement
such that I wouldn't actually see the
intermediate parts. So it's almost like
the it's almost like the resources that
I have here would kind of predictively
go here so that when I make the eye
movement there is no resource that is
actually computing the intermediary
parts for me to actually experience the
motion blur. And so that's the general
gist of this kind of idea of predictive
remapping. And my contribution is that I
think that the computations and the and
and the and and the and the way to think
about this is in is in the terms of
forces is in the terms of Newtonian
mechanics. And uh like I said um you can
look at the paper um um if if you want
to know more ask me questions after uh
this talk. Now let's get to the more fun
part of this talk rather than the more u
I guess uh
technically intense part. So ultimately
right like you know the connection is to
understand these temporal dynamics in
the brain in order to be able to
understand consciousness and eventually
apply it to artificial intelligence
systems. And so the first part of this
is to understand
um consciousness, right? And you know I
think that you know I normally use this
example as a um as a um
as a metaphor to understand conscious or
conscious or conscious behavior or
collective intelligence.
So what you see is that you know this
process called murmmoration by the way
and so what you see is that each of
these birds right they are on one level
individuals
but on another level they're a
collective they're part of a group
they're part of a larger network
and what you see is that you know at
some level of description you know you
see it looks like a chaotic system very
random very stochastic but then at
another level you start to see this kind
of collective behavior, this emergent
property where they're kind of moving in
a very structured manner. And so I
normally think about humans in this
sense, right? I normally think of
thought in this sense or even neurons.
And I'm not the first to think about
this. Giorgio Perezi who won the Nobel
Prize, a physicist kind of used the bird
flocking as one of the uh systems that
he studied to understand complex
systems.
And so one of the things that I'm doing
right now is to understand
um these systems in terms of dynamical
systems in terms of attractors
specifically and you know many people
have done this before but not
applying it to the question or to the
phenomena that I will be applying to
which I'll talk about in the next slides
and so we have these things called
attractors in physics and you know here
I'm showing you a strange attractor a
tourist attractor a cycled attractor and
then here's the point attractive.
So just to give some intuition, right?
You can think about a pendulum. If I had
a pendulum for example and I move that
pendulum and I let it go, right? That
pendulum at some point
will stop right at the center. So
there's a particular point that's
attracting that pendulum, right? And
that's an intuition that can give you
about what a point attractor is, right?
A simple pendulum, right? the the
dynamics of that of that of that system
reflects a point attractor.
And so is there a tractor? Is there an
attractor that can help us understand
consciousness? And specifically what I
mean in this term by conscious is just
mental thought, right? I I think of
mental thought as or mental content as
kind of something you need to understand
in order to understand uh consciousness
or put forth a theory of consciousness.
And so one question that I think needs
to be asked is or or or or something
that I believe is that to understand
consciousness and leverage the insights
to build conscious AI, we need a
database to use to study and ultimately
uncover the fundamental laws governing
consciousness.
And so I would argue specifically in the
scientific domain in the academic there
is no such database.
Right? at the very most you have
consciousness researchers looking at
maybe 50 subjects or two people in the
lab and an fMRI study and you know it's
I don't think that data is sufficient in
order to understand something as
dramatic if you may as consciousness
and here's an example I want you to ask
yourself like is there someone in the
world right now having the same exact
thought as you at this very moment in
time right and if there was How would
you even measure this? Right? There is I
mean I'm sure Google has this data but
they're not interested in actually
studying consciousness. They're
interested in selling you that you
don't want to buy. Right? But in short,
right? Like from you know when you think
about the study of consciousness and the
history of consciousness there's not a
lot of there isn't any data set that you
can actually mind or study to explore to
actually give you intuitions about what
possibly could be consciousness or
collective intelligence and how you
could even apply that to an a conscious
AI right if if if such was even
possible.
And so that is what led to the this you
know the the introduction of
conversation net. And so conversation
that is a repository
that um has spontaneous human
conversations in real time
that you can actually use as a way to
measure whether or not
uh for example is there someone saying
the same exact thing as you in this
exact time. Right? You can start to
understand these types of questions or
at least study these types of questions.
And so we just released
uh the third uh database for
conversation net. And just to give you
an example of that, you can sort of go
on the conversation net uh uh uh uh uh
um website and you can just download
this data for free and uh sort of um you
know um sort of try to understand or try
to sort of
mine this data, right? And a lot of this
data are anom anonymized uh consent of
people and they're coming from my other
company Figbox that uh you know one of
the core attributes is connecting people
uh through uh uh uh 20-minute
conversations. And so I just found that
as a as a as a as a as a useful way to
uh sort of u um support scientific
research. And so you know there's there
are some people in the audience that may
be aware of imageet
which is a database that basically uh
was foundational to um uh introducing
data into machine learning systems and
as a result you know ImageNet was used
to build AlexNet uh and u you know uh
here's professor Hilton who recently won
the Nobel Prize last year but and this
is his student uh Alex who built AlexNet
and So a lot of this uh we think that
you know conversation that is is is is
really important into uh not just
studying consciousness and complexity
but also uh can help in building
conscious AI more humanlike AI right
studying human conversations spontaneous
conversations and so on and you know
Alex net led to let's say for example
some of the software is used for facial
recognition self-driving cars and so
forth
and so what are some of the things that
we want to use on conversation as far as
like to study uh uh uh um these types of
uh uh properties, right? One of the
things we you know some of the things
can be this idea of self-recurrence,
inter aent synchronicity, you know,
phase relationship and variance and then
uh propagation and variance. And so let
me just give you a simple example of
that. So here's a case of of of
someone's conversation, right? This
individual was having a conversation,
right? And what we did is we measured
I'm sorry. I'm showing an instance where
the person is saying the same exact
phrase at different points in time. And
what you can see is you can see kind of
this structure in this uh in this uh uh
in this uh what we call mocognitive maps
where you kind of see the same structure
emerge when the person is saying the
same thing at the same ex um at
different points in time. And so this is
the some of the ways in which you can
start to measure
um and and and visualize right these
sort of things that I've uh these sort
of u um these sort of phenomenons that
we're interested in exploring and we
think of these phenomenons as temporal
invariance right things that kind of
have this predictive pattern that you
can kind of tease out from this data set
in order to understand thing uh uh the
idea of u you know whether or not you
know um there is some emergent property
happening as people are having different
thoughts in different speeches in
different parts in space.
And so here is just a simple example of
how you would think about um um um
attractors, right? So what you can see
is that there are four attractors in
this kind of fictitious uh uh
simulation. And each individual, you can
think of that as every individual having
some thought, right, in some time
window. And so each individual in some
ways are being attracted to a particular
type of thought. And so let's say for
example some famous person just died
right um you know you can imagine that
that you know a lot of people are
talking about those things and so
they're attracted to that thought right
within some window in time right and so
this is kind of again this is fictitious
right this is not actual data but this
just gives you an idea of how you can um
how I'm thinking about using attractors
to understand and and and uh uh uh this
idea of of thoughts or consciousness and
again how you can start to mind this
type of data to to ask these very kind
of sci-fi questions that you know um
prior to conversation that you you
really can't answer these questions
because there's no data to answer it
now you know ultimately right you know a
lot of what I just talked about is very
new and you know very althogonal and
very different from the way people think
about these things and I understand that
um and So what we can just do is, you
know, is there a way for us to learn
something about the data that we're
we're we're measuring and just add some
sort of temporal invariance layer to
these networks that, you know, OpenAI
and Anthorpic and Gemini, right? These
LLMs, right? These uh these uh
transformers, right? And you know, I'm
not particularly um um uh optimistic
about that path. I think to get AGI we
need to fundamentally build new systems
that are radically different right but
one of the things that we've done um is
build digital twins
right and so this is just a this is and
this was done actually a lot I I I've
included these individuals that you see
at the bottom because they kind of
inform the way that I think about they
kind of teach me to be honest the way
that I think about uh artificial
networks so this is um someone like this
a brother to me uh Kuramusa
uh you know he's a machine learning
expert in in London and then this is
Daniel Olds he him and him him and I
work uh with uh the conversation at a
database and we try to understand
systems and uh I should mention that
this right here is actually uh uh for
the most part built and trained by uh
Timothy um who um uh is another uh young
brilliant individual that um uh works
with us on conversation. And so
basically what we did is we we we took
these LLMs and we trained them on
conversation net data to see whether or
not they improve performance or not. And
so in short, you know, there are ways in
which we can use the LLMs now to try to
understand whether or not uh they will
sort of create more humanlike responses
and things like that. But like I said,
I'm not particularly convinced. And I
think um the endeavor of maybe uh
building new types of systems uh could
potentially be fruitful and
groundbreaking. And so I go back to this
paper that I initially uh brought up in
um uh at the start of my talk um where
it's like how do we build systems that
think in time? How do we build AGI that
think in time are are predictive that
can maybe create causal causal temporal
inferences and things like that.
So,
I've been sort of talking to a very um
you know, you know, he he's he's pretty
out there this this guy and and I love
him for that. And him and I talk a lot
about systems and um how to think about
systems and um you know, uh Rob, you
know, we've been thinking about and and
sort of playing around with this idea of
polychronous systems. So, let me explain
that a little bit.
What I'm showing you here is a network
that has two layers. Layers I and layer
J.
P I P2 and P3. They represent uh let's
say C A and T.
What defines a polychronous group is the
temporal pattern
um that um that leads it to let's say
for example the second wave. So in this
case here PI is connected to cat with a
latency of one. P2 is connected to cat
with a latency of five. P3 is connected
to cat with a latency of nine. Right?
For this word cat to be encoded
there needs to be an activation key and
a delay key. So in a sense the
activation key needs to be uh configured
in a way by which they all activate this
node at the same exact time. And so you
need an activation key that is almost an
offset to the delay key. And so if you
were to add this together like let's say
for example we add 8 to um 8 to 9 8 to 1
sorry you would get 9 0 to 9 you would
get 9 four to 5 you would get nine. And
so in a sense
if you just took this very simple
example as the initial measure or the
initial way by which the network is
computed or encoding words. You can kind
of instantly see that it has to do some
temporal computation
for it to encode a word. This is
radically different from let's say the
way LLMs are now where you have let's
say C as a vector that has a series of
numbers. You have A as a vector with a
series of numbers. You have T as a
vector with a series of numbers. And
they're just basically doing these
statistical correlations with these
tokens. Right? But what's happening here
with these polychronous systems is that
the system is actually having to think
about the temporal order and the
temporal differences in order to encode
time, right? And so sorry, in order to
encode words and so what you can get is
an increase in representational
capacity, right? You can also get
emergent behaviors like self-organizing
behaviors. I don't want to go too much
into that, but I can I'm more than happy
to explain what that is in the in the
question section. But in short, right,
like this is kind of the the the work
that I've been doing uh from a both, you
know, from from from the biological side
and the stuff that I've been doing from
an artificial side. Again, I understand
that this may not be what you guys are
uh uh are used to hearing when it comes
to like active inference, but hopefully
some of the ways that I'm thinking about
things, at least one or two of the
things that I've talked about kind of
informs um or helps think differently
about some of the questions that you all
u may be engaged in. Um and um yeah um I
appreciate again the
um the uh the uh the opportunity to talk
and again a lot of the uh pictures that
you've seen dur through through the
course of this talk is just the people
that um sort of um have are are critical
right to either getting the data
analyzing the data conversations that
I've had with the data or just some of
my work right and so um yeah I I would
entertain any uh questions or or
comments. Thank you again. And um it's
glad to um share some of these ideas,
some of these crazy some some a little
crazy, but it was good to share them.
Awesome.
Thank you.
All right. All right.
So, for people watching live, they can
write a question in the live chat. I'll
read one and uh we'll just go from
there. I wrote down a few things as
well. So, Hongju wrote, "How many
inevitable
overlappings could there be
between complexity versus consciousness?
Is it safe enough for us to assume
analyzing complexity is inevitably
connected to explanation of
consciousness?"
Let let me just reread it. How many
inevitable overlapping could there be
between complexity versus subjective and
phenomenal consciousness?
So maybe just how do we think about that
overlapping?
>> That's a good question.
>> I mean I'm just going to leave this uh
this uh image because it's so beautiful
and so if no one likes my answer at
least they have something good look good
to look at. So basically right like when
I think about I think that's an
excellent question because ultimately
complexity is connected to consciousness
right understanding the the different
scales of things right and then
eventually understanding how
um that can inform uh the question of
subjective experience and things like
that. Let me be a little bit more
precise with my answer.
Um you know I actually just um connected
with the Santa Fe Institute um in uh New
Mexico which they sort of pioneered
complexity science and you know one of
the things that I proposed is
understanding
uh using um the brain for example to
understand certain laws and then seeing
whether or not they scale across
different phenomenons. let's say for
example societal groups or uh you know
uh cells or uh humans or you know other
organisms right and so I think
ultimately complexity and studying it um
is important the only thing about that
is that
there have been previous work that have
shown that under complexity stability
breaks down so the more complex you
study something apparently right the
more instable this unstable the system
becomes. And so I think the challenge
there or I think the opportunity is how
do we study complexity?
And you know the question of can
complexity bring forth some stable uh
phenomenon or some stable predictions uh
that mimics kind of um um you know um
biological systems for example and the
idea of thought and conversations or you
know u systems that are adaptive and
optimal and so on. So I think yes in
short complexity is is is is is is one
of the frontiers in understanding um
consciousness and even bringing us to uh
a better understanding of uh how to
build conscious AIs.
Awesome. All right. Next question is
from Bert. He wrote there's two
questions. So we'll just do one at a
time. First question. Could you explain
the mechanics implied in the spring
visualization?
Yeah, that's a again I whoever asked
that question I will um um um encourage
them to read the paper but by mechanics
I assume uh that the person means the
sets of equations or the um
the uh the rules that that shift these
springs in in a particular way. So each
of these so so you what I have done is
that I have I I I I I think about
neural fields as force fields.
So you can imagine that there is a
particular force
or sorry there's a moss in the in the
field that is kind of perturbing these
springs in specific directions
and the motivation for these mosses are
very uh biological
right so you can imagine
I see
a very colorful object in my in my
visual scene
Right? That colorful object you can
think of as a moss by which the springs
will kind of move towards especially if
I want to look at that object. And so
the kinematics
just thinking about neurons as particles
right under Newtonian mechanics you'll
see that they undergo kind of this F= ma
right these kind of ideas where the mass
and the acceleration right they will
determine the force by which that
particular thing experiences and so
that's why
uh these uh these springs right they
that's why you know I think of them as
the Newtonian law remapping, right? They
undergo these forces and these forces
are just effectively um ways by which
these neurons are allocating their
attention dynamically in space and time
in order to kind of provide sensitivity
to particular things that you want to
attend to. And so the kinematics is
basically you know uh Newtonian force
equations and uh you know putting that
under more biological constraints right
like let I I'll give another very simple
example you can imagine for example when
you you normally hear when people are
like um in very high stakes situations
they'll say I couldn't see anything it
it felt like you know it felt like I I
was undergoing tunnel vision in a sense
Right.
In that sense, I would argue that
the the the force that was being exerted
in that person's visual system was so
strong that it pulled them outside of
their elast kind of like this larger
thing, right? So if I wanted to look at
something right now, my neurons need to
kind of still it needs to attend to that
area, but it kind of needs to leave a
little bit of resources in my periphery
so that I can actually see what's in my
in the corner of my eye. And so that's
what these elastic fields are for. They
kind of control for the system from
overcommitting, right? And so it's kind
of these biological constraints along
with these kind of Newtonian uh
kinematics that I've combined to create
this kind of novel computational field
of research. And so you know maybe I
wasn't may you know again whoever that
person is they could read the paper or
connect with me on Figbox. I'll love to
uh work out the equations with them if
they like. Uh but that's kind of the
idea here. And these types of things you
can imagine are useful for like computer
vision. Uh if you want to like build a
robotic eye for example, right? Does it
undergo a retinal topic mechanics? How
do you create constraints where the
robot doesn't completely converge on a
single point but has some kind of
processing in the periphery? And again
these elastic fields there is no
biological evidence for it. It's
something that I have kind of predicted
and there are particular I'm hoping
experimentalists at some point uh will
kind of uh give this idea some um um
some uh some tension and and and explore
because I think they are uh key into
understanding um active sensing and
active vision specifically.
>> Cool. Yeah. Just a few comments on that
and then I'll ask Bert's second
question.
The idea of spring-loaded systems,
either coupled oscillators or springs
like uh pullback attractors for joints.
It's often used in active inference like
in the 20122 textbook chapter 8 has
examples of spring joints. And then we
can generalize that a little bit more to
energy based models where there's a
potential function like a pullback or a
gravity function
>> as you move away. So like in this flat
circle with a spring pulling laterally,
you could think about the Zaxis there
being it's like a bowl and then there's
like more pullback as you go up the
edges of the bowl. And it it is the
generalization of Newtonian mechanics to
have the basian mechanics which allows
for different energy functions to exist
for a given state space. So I think it's
totally on the right track and I'm sure
you'll find many connections as you
learn about these.
>> Yeah.
Okay,
>> that's an excellent point, Daniel. And I
actually want to say one last thing
about that.
>> Um the I actually use the the
equilibrium term this FE
right that this equilibrium force is
actually the force that relaxes the
spring back. So I use hook and I that is
motivated by Hook's law. So as the
system gets to you can imagine if I if I
pull a spring really hard it could
break, right? So as the system kind of
gets to its what I call the elastic
limit,
the spring will then pull it back and
then that that that's really basically
what resets it back to its equilibrium
state. So you're exactly right that that
gravitate that pullback spring system is
also in my model and you know um you
know we you know I found that you know
the law that actually governs this uh
remapping obeys Newtonian it's it's akin
to Newtonian's uh uh uh law of
gravitation right and uh you know um um
it's not exactly uh Newton's law of
gravitation But it's very similar. The
exponent in this case is 1.6.
So yeah, excellent.
That also reminds me of uh Lachlan
Kent's work on mental gravity where he
explores both the qualitative metaphors
and that sort of quantitative
gravitational and the different
exponents associated with with pullback
outside of the uh energy minima. And
then okay the second question of Bert
was
>> I think there's a third question. Oh.
Oh, yes. Okay. Bert wrote, "Are LLM
conversations with chat GPT a huge
conversation net like source? What would
be possible with such large data sets?"
>> Sorry, I didn't understand that
question.
>> Um, are LLM conversations, so like human
talking to a language model or just to
LLMs,
a huge conversation net like source?
What would be possible with such large
data sets?
Yeah, I mean um just to clarify
conversation that is human to human
conversations.
Um if I understood the question
correctly, Daniel and maybe you could
help me. Um
so the indivi the person that asked the
question has proposed two scenarios. The
first is an LLM and a human having a
conversation, right? Like you do with
chbt and so on and then a human having a
conversation. And how would such data um
I guess um help or um enhance
uh or affect that interaction in in
those two cases.
>> Yeah. Basically as the overall
availability of conversation data all
the all the combinations human human
>> agent agent etc. as we as the amount
becomes so vast,
>> what kinds of of analyses or what kinds
of models become more possible
>> other than just better recapitulation of
chat?
>> Yeah. Well, I will ask the person to uh
uh put the onus on on the person that
asked the question because u you know
that's kind of what I wanted to inspire
for us to to sort of answer that
question together, right? And that's why
the data is open source, right? But a
low hanging fruit answer would be you
would just use that data to fine-tune
these models, right? And see whether or
not you get different results, right?
Um, as far as the humanto human
interaction, I'm very excited about that
because, you know, one of the reasons
why I sort of thought about this this
this stuff was what if who you married
in the future was someone that you
constantly had the same thought at the
same exact time? What if that's the way
that you found your partner? That every
time you had a conversation, that person
was being synchronized on some part of
the world. I find that deeply profound
that like perhaps this entanglement akin
to like how particles are entangled
could be a way to match people right to
find like okay is my person right the
person that I'm constantly thinking
about and we already see this actually
right in the way when you really really
are close with someone you kind of
finish their sentences or sometimes
they're like oh I was just thinking
about you so I have this strong
intuition that these things already
exist we just don't have a way to
measure that and So conversation that is
my vision of one day being able to study
these spooky actions at a distance as
Einstein would say right and um you know
there's actually a data set right now on
on conversationet where we have two
groups having a conversation at the same
exact time and so people right now can
just mine that data and explore that and
see whether or not you kind of pick up
on these resonance right and so you know
that is kind of the two uh ways that I
would say uh you can sort of use that
data and and deploy them in the world,
right? Um and you know, like I said, as
we continue to build conversation that
you know uh this amount of data that
we're trying to collect is going to be
unprecedented. And I'll say one last
thing.
Normally when we think about systems,
we think that when we when when they
have this sort of when their internal d
like you can imagine that you have this
spontaneous conversations that human
beings are having that in those
conversations they're not like forced.
They're not scripted. They're not
pretended in a sense, right?
And in that sense, if you were to use
that type of data, you're able to pick
up the more natural properties of what
it means to be a human being, right?
You're able to pick up the more
spontaneous parts of cognition because
the data set, right, is very spontaneous
and isn't scripted. So maybe a lot of
the conversations that have been trained
on on on the LLMs are conversations that
are scripted and so they don't capture
real human dynamics, right? the
subtleties, the noise, the the the the
the stochasticity. And so again, it
offers another avenue into building, you
know, new types of systems, ones that
are more creative, right? Rather than
probabilistic, for example, right? One
that are one that invent
um uh uh context rather than find them,
right? That's what that that's how I
would think about it in this in this
very moment.
>> Nice. I agree. I think it
prepares the stage for systems that are
part of societies of cognitive agents
rather than just like an extended
monologue or a book that's univocal
>> is going to be continuing on a thematic
thread which is good for coherence but
it's still is is very single player. Um
okay last question. Um, we'll
address this and then also feel free
just to close with like where where are
you going from here? Um, what happens
next? But here's the last question.
Simone,
>> sorry to cut you sorry.
>> Are there more questions or that's the
actually the last question.
>> Um, the the this is the penultimate
question.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> I don't know what that means, but I I
I'll take your word for it.
>> Yes. Simona wrote, "What metric would
you say we would end up using to detect
or measure if an AI does become
conscious? Turing tests have become
outdated. Where do you see being the
next measuring bar?"
>> What's the name of the person that asked
the question?
>> Simona.
>> Shimona. Oh, of course.
>> Of course.
>> Yeah. She she she she she would ask that
question. I know Shimona, by the way.
Anyways,
um this is actually a question that um I
was asked by um one of the leading um
pioneers in AI right now. I forgot. Oh,
Josh Boach uh you know he asked me that
same question or at least their group
asked me that same question.
I am of the opinion that to build
conscious AI
first of all I don't think that any
human being can build a conscious AI.
Paradoxically, what I think must happen
for
uh conscious AI to occur is you build
kind of the the the the uh the um the
foundational pieces like the clay by
which that AI system can become
conscious on its own independent of the
architecture of the system. So let's say
for example Shimona and I wanted to
build a conscious AI. What we would do
is we would kind of have ideas of the
building blocks of consciousness and
then we would use that to build the
system and the architecture and then we
would leave the system to its own and
then come back maybe later and say hey
you know are you conscious or do you
start to behave very much like let's say
for example we use the human right as a
measurement right as a human being. So
in a sense that's a it's a paradoxical
answer right in the sense that we can't
build a conscious AI because
consciousness I don't think is something
you can directly build it's something
that emerges from a system and so we
would have to create or understand the
properties of consciousness right as I'm
trying to do with conversation that or
not just me but hopefully everyone in
the audience in the community and um you
know build these substrates that um that
um that eventually uh can um lead to AIS
that become begin to have this kind of
self-organization,
self-emergence, right? They begin to
have an intention, right? Um and so I
think I think I think that's very
important and if I were to go on a limb
and say what is the exact property that
is needed or like two things is a
self-awareness of course but some
concept of death
I think that the AI must invent some
concept of death which obviously is
going to be based upon like compute
right right like the AI must be aware
that if I don't power myself in some
sense I will stop functioning and I
think a concept of death is foundational
to an AI becoming conscious. Um because
I think that a lot of the things that we
humans do some parts right is driven by
our sense of finality right especially
in the western context. I would say from
a more African metaphysics death is
probably not as high in cognition. It's
more about community and village and and
spirituality. But I think from a from a
western metaphysics point of view, death
is act death is a key driving force in
cognition and the ways by which
cognitions kind of preserve themselves
in a sense.
>> Interesting. So sort of in closing, what
are your next moves? What are you
looking for? And how can people learn
more and and collaborate and everything?
>> Yeah. Well, my f my my my ultimate move
is to become top 15 on a particular
list. Um,
someone, you know, but but I would say
no, that was just a joke. But I would
say this that my next move is, you know,
continue to work with Christopher Neil.
Um, you know, exploring options uh as
far as uh, you know, what I want to do
next as far as science. Um I also have a
company uh called Figbox right which I
mentioned briefly where I'm building
that and trying to uh become the Trojan
horse of social media uh u in a sense of
trying to facilitate and connect people
through human conversations and and and
and u you know that's something that
that that I'm working on heavily. Um I'm
also uh open to collaborators right like
um and um you know I'm you know I have
several grants for example one of them
at the Santa Fe Institute um right now
um so you know um for conversation at to
scale we definitely need uh people to
fund the service and things like that um
I also do other things in Africa where I
support like African thinkers and
entrepreneurs I'm very passionate about
that I think that uh science needs um to
um be more interdisciplinary um um in
order to to to to tap into the the
knowledge and the in the abilities of
people across different spectrums um as
well as gender as well. So I'm very
passionate about the inclusivity of
science making sure women are able to
contribute uh making sure that you know
uh people of different cultures and
races are able to contribute. I think
that in order to solve complex problems,
right, an interdisiplinary approach is
foundational and I don't think that
science is doing a very good job of
that. So that's another thing that I
work on. Um and so yeah, that that's
kind of like um you know um kind of the
my future plans and um you know um I I
really am very humbled that you've um
entertained to to have me speak and uh
of course I would love to build
relationship with you at some point as
well and so thank you. Yeah,
>> thank you. Lot of food for thought, lot
of material to explore. So, please be in
touch and till next time. Thanks again.
>> Thanks, D.
>> Bye.
I hope that wasn't too mathematically
dense, you know, because it could be
intense a little bit.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.